先生 はい ティラサンガラという
ティラサンガラっていうのがですね
スギルは T H I R A S A N G A R A ですか
TI でしょうね ちょっと待って
もう一度見ます  T I L A
うん  そう思ったらティラサンガラがなかったのでっていうことは
チラで硬い硬い約束がなかったので
約束しなかったので頂かなかったのかなと思ったんですけど
そんなだからこれ侮辱にならないでしょうね
だからチッタさんのすごいもう社会の偉い人でしょうね
社会の偉い人に言ってはならない単語を言ったんです
とにかく あの似てるケースが昔フィリピンで起きたんです
あのフィリピンでマルコス大統領が
あの独裁政権をやってた時のマルコス大統領の奥さんが
ただ飲み屋さんで仕事していた人なんです
大した女ではなかったんです
ものすごい貧乏で どこかの飲み屋さんで
そこでマルコスさんがもう美人だからね
で 結婚して それがマルコスが大統領になったところ
これ大統領夫人だからね
それから性格は全部変わっちゃったんです
国の財産は盗みたい放題盗んだりして
まあもう選挙にも出ようとしたんだからね
マルコスさんが亡くなってから裁判もかけられてあってね
それどうなったかわからない
ものすごいね もう一番有名なのは彼女のこの靴の数でしょ
で 他のことは言うこともなくてね
で その時もこの野党側の誰か誰かね
ちょこっともうマルコス夫人があんまり調子に乗ってすごいことやってるんだから
これ一言言ったみたい
公でどこかで これでその言った人みんなやられちゃったんです
マルコスさんに 奥さんにと向こうは政権取っているんだから
独裁政権 だからまあそれは隠したいんですよ
結局は過去 だからチッタさんはもう大富豪家になって
もうしっかりしている人がまたお寺までね
すごい大きなお寺まで作って
全部面倒見てる人が だからまあそういう信者さんで
だから何か気づくことを言っちゃったんですけど
まあこれはまた食べ物に関わるものなんですね
聞いたのはどうです？ああ
全部ちゃんと用意してるんですね
でももうティラサングラだけはないんですねと言ったんだから
そこでクルンとなっちゃって
いきなりあのねとエピソードを始めたんです
だからこれ ティラッサとアングラで読むか
あの硬いという言葉単語でティラッサとはティラ
ティラですから Lだからね
ゴマにはやりますけど
ティラって言えばゴマですからね
結局は ティラッサになってくると何ですか？何でアングラって
アングラって指って意味でもあるしね
節という指のね これにも使う場合もあるし
だからもうとにかく私は分かりません
もう調べてもないしね
まあ事象は大体注釈書のパーリ語に事象は出てこないしね
ティラサングリカーっていうのは違いますか？ だからそれは別に
それは女性名詞だからね
すいません ちょっと時間がいいと思うんですけど
質問してよろしいですか？あの
人間はですね 自分が一番大切だと思っていると思うんですね
お坊さんの王様が徳釈に一番大切なのは何だって聞いて
自分だっていう風に答えてるようにですね
これは自分が一番大事だと思ってると思うんですが
シンハラ語の中にシンハラ語の中にですね
友のために命を捨てるというような表現がありまして
パーリ語ではジーリタンピッサカッターヤパリキチャッタンホーという文章があるんですね
友人のために命を捨てるとなってくるんですよね
ここはどういうふうに理解したらいいのかというのが
うん まあそのまま理解するんですけどね
あれはまあやっぱりこの友達同士の感情ですよ
何でもやってあげるっていうことでしょう
本物の友達だったらね
例えば自分の友達が暴力団に捕まられてもうクタクタ殴られていると
とにかくそちらへ飛ぶ
飛んで自分に体力があってもなくても関係なく
殴り返したりして友達を守るということをするって
そんなそんなような友人友情の気持ちなんですよ
命でも捨てて惜しまないというね
それは普通な常識的な理解でよろしいと思います
親が子供を思うようなそういう気持ち
最近の親はちょっとあれなんですけど
子供のためならば死んでもいいというのは
その まあ似ているかも違うかもね
やっぱり友情と親の関係っていうのはまた違う感情でしょ
まあ似ているかもしれませんです
でも友情は親子関係じゃないんだからね
対等の関係でしょ  もう一つお願いしたいんですが
印伝教の中にですね ウィラーナサムッタの番にアンニャティッティアンニャティッティアという外道の経典がありまして
その外道の方が苦は自作なり
苦は他作なり 苦は自作であり
同時に他作であり  4つ目が苦は自作でもなく
他作でもなく 因によるものでもないという 4つの説を説くんですけれども
で サーリプッタ尊者に
お釈迦様はどんな風に説かれるんだという質問をして
サーリプッタ尊者は苦っていうのは現象なりという風に答えて
自作であるとか他作であるとか
そういうふうには答えていらっしゃらないんですね
それが仏教の考え方だなと思ったんですけども
どちらかというと それまで私は苦は自作なりというふうに思ってたので
なんかすごいちょっとガーンときちゃって
苦は自作なりという言い方は仏教としては適当じゃないのかなという気がしてきたんですけれども
どうなんでしょうか  これ日本語で考えるんだから
そういう問題起こるんです
アッタンカタン ドゥッカン
パランカタン ドゥッカン
アッタンカタンチャ パランカタンチャ
ドゥッカン ソカドゥッカン両方ありますけどね
ネーアッタンカタンナパランカタンソコドゥッカンというインドの論理の 4つのステージですよ
アッタカタンというのは By self という我なんですよ
自分の自我が苦しみを作っているのかと
パランカタンというのはタガという神我ですよ
神様のことなんです 神様が設定しているんでしょうかと
あるいは両方でやっているのかと
あるいはどちらでもなく苦が現れるのかと
自分でも他人でもなく
という 4つなんですね
ネーアッタンカタンナパランカタンアディチソンパニソコドゥッカンというのは突然現れるものであるとという
ことで 因縁によって現れますよと
それは別にそれが真理ですよ
自我がないんだから 現象だけでしょ
全て 私と言ったっても現象で
他人といったっても現象で
一切は現象ですよ サンカーラでしょ
サンカーラは因縁によって生まれるんだからね
それでですね そのあとでそれだけだとそれだったら我々もちょいちょいになってるよと言って
で さらにサーリプッタ沙門がそのあと違うところはこれなんだというふうにして
二次会おっしゃってるんですね
それがですね テーワタ アンニャッタ パッサ パティサンウェディッサン ウェディッサンティ ネータン ターナン ヴィッチャ
うん？ちょっと聞き取れなかった
アンニャッタ パッサ  アンニャッタ パッサ
うん  触による この意味がちょっとよくわからないんですけど
この間ずっとそれについて喋ってますけど
私は そのテーマだけに
あの  昨日喋りましたけど
すいません 出席してなかった
今最近もかなりいろんなところでそのテーマ使ってます
パッサ パッサ パティサンウェディッサンっていうことね
ヴェーダナー 感覚が触れることによって現れるんであって
それは六根に情報が触れることなんです
苦であろうが楽であろうが
六根に情報が触れることで現れるんです
眼耳鼻舌身意に色声香味触法というものが触れると感覚が生まれるんです
感覚が 感覚は苦であろうが楽であろうが
人が判断するんです 昨日は第一
第二 第三という三段階でそれを説明しましたけど
かなりのものは言いましたけどね
そのポイント そのポイントなんです
私は昨日説明してたのは
昨日だけじゃない 今いろんなところで
まぁこれでやりましょうとか
時々私もいろいろありますからね
大体まぁいろんなところで今そのポイントは言ってはいるんです
テーマは何であろうとも
このポイントは持っていくんです
それでネータンの取り方を
ネータン ターナン ヴィッチャというのはありえないって意味なんでしょ
ただのありえないって